- Welcome to another YouTube hangout.
Super excited to be here with a new friend
and special guest, Jordan,
who has an amazing podcast.
I'm going to be on it shortly.
- That's right.
- Talking about charm.
It's called The Art of Charm.
One of the top 50 podcasts.
You can go check out, download.
He is on today to help us
talk about how to be yourself.
How to talk yourself
into and out of almost
any situation that you want to.
And I'm super excited to learn
how I can maybe be a little
more charming myself.
Jordan, welcome aboard man.
- Thanks for having me, man.
I appreciate it.
I love the background.
Are those acoustic panels
with photos printed on them?
- I wish that I was that smart.
- Oh man.
- They are just canvas panels.
- Oh, okay.
- They are not acoustic.
- They look like acoustic panels.
I mean I have the same
thing in my studio here,
but I didn't put photos on them.
I thought what a great idea.
- We can combine our two ideas together.
Yeah, I like that.
Now, are you shooting video
for your podcast as well?
- I don't so you're off the hook
on all of the things you did
to make yourself look so beautiful today.
It's an audio-only program.
We'll use video so that I can see you
to make sure that you're
not like playing Candy Crush
while I'm interviewing you,
but I don't air the video.
Which I think benefits me personally,
having a face for radio
and most of my guests,
who get self conscious, you know,
busy being a general, not busy being on TV
or things like that.
But I love the YouTube format.
I tell people all the time
if I had to go back and start over,
I've been doing this show for 10 years,
but if I had to go back and start over,
YouTube hands down.
I mean it didn't exist then.
Even Gary Vee was using like Viddler
or something back then,
which pry doesn't exist anymore.
But YouTube is a better format
so props to you for getting on that.
- Cool. Well before we dive too deep,
can you just give my audience a little bit
of an overview of the The Art of Charm,
what you're all about, what you're doing,
a little background.
- Absolutely, so what I
do at The Art of Charm,
there's a show of course by
the same name which I host,
but what we are is both
a show and a school.
The school is located in LA
and people fly in from all over the world
and learn about things like
non-verbal communication,
body language, persuasion,
influence, networking,
things like that.
So a lot of soft skills that we make,
I like to say we turn
'em into hard skills,
although that technically makes no sense,
but what I mean by that is,
instead of being like just
be there for the person,
it's like no, no, what does that mean.
What does it mean to
give emotional support.
What does it mean to be persuasive.
It doesn't mean this,
that, and the other thing.
It's not what you read
on some blog article
by some buddy who's trying
to do content marketing.
I'll have a real person in
here talking about this.
And so, on the show, we try to also teach
this very similar and same content.
So I'll like, I had Tony Hawk on recently
and he wasn't just talking about skating,
he was talking about look
man, building a business
in this world that nobody
cared about for 10 years
and then became this cut throat
competitive market space.
Like why did he choose to make that brand.
How has he protected his brand.
How has he become famous in the face
of all of this corporate
industrial might in his face.
I had General McChrystal on,
who was our theater commander
in Afghanistan and Iraq.
Special forces guy and just,
he was dismissed by Obama.
So I went through like, how
do you make tough decisions
where people could die and then also
on the other end of that if you screw up,
not only are people going to die,
but then your career is over.
And so, I talk about the
decision-making process
when it comes to that because I think
that those of us where
our biggest decision
is do I go to Starbucks or Coffee Bean
can also benefit from
different modes of thinking.
So I try to convey mindset in the show
and again it's all stuff that
practical and applicable,
not just like you can do it.
Because I think inspiration
is cheap, you know.
It's so easy to find and
actually hard to apply
and become successful.
So those are the people
I like to deconstruct.
- I love it.
Now, talking about being
able to talk yourself
into or out of any situation,
what are some of the things
that people need to keep in mind?
Or when somebody shows up at your school,
kind of day one newbie,
what are some of the
most foundational things
that you need to break or
they need to understand
before they're ready to move forward
with some of the tactics?
- Sure, definitely.
This is kind of a funny question in a way.
Because there are two
sides to the learning coin
the first day at AOC.
The first time people come in
generally our perception
of how good we are at,
how I should say how well we have a handle
on these skills is always way off.
People either come in thinking
look I'm really good with people,
I'm great at generating rapport,
I'm pretty good at reading body language,
I'm pretty good at the confidence thing,
but I got to work on A, B, C, D.
And I'm like okay great.
We take that down on the intake form
and we have a conversation about that.
Or they come in and this
is more like guys like me,
come in and go, I'm not that good at this,
I'm not that good that, I'm
really not good at this,
and then I have to, as an instructor,
my team in LA, Johnny and AJ and Fern
and all those cats down in LA,
they have to take that guy and go no,
here's actual proof that
you're better at these things
than you know and now we're
going to build the skill set.
So one of the things that
we do on the very first day
is we video tape people
in real interactions
and then we show them their body language,
their non-verbal communication,
the way they sit, stand, walk and talk.
And either they're thrilled,
because we're building on this foundation
that they didn't know they had
or they're ready, I won't say
horrendously disappointed,
but other people are less than thrilled,
but they are then ready to learn
because their ego has
kind of been white washed
by the video tape because
that tape don't lie.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, it does. So nobody has that...
For me, I think about people's
relationship with money.
I don't think people grow up
having a healthy relationship with money.
They either, like it's everything
and it's the only thing that matters,
or like I don't deserve
money, like I shouldn't,
I can't go out and get that.
So at some point you need to
learn the right relationship.
And so I think it's the same thing.
People don't have the right
expectations going in.
That's interesting.
What are some of the basics then?
Like I want to be more charming.
I can see how that's
going to impact my career,
my business, my relationships.
What are some of the foundational things
that you work people through?
- Sure, so I'd love to
give a practical drill
slash exercise that everybody watching,
hanging out with us can
actually apply right away
starting today, is that cool?
Does that fit your model?
- Yeah, do it. I love it.
Can I do something?
Am I moving around, what am I doing?
- Yeah, moving around.
Well okay, so essentially,
and I'm going to stand up too
and I know that made no
difference what so ever.
(laughs)
When I sit, I'm as tall as
I am when I stand on camera.
So the way that this works,
this is called the doorway drill
and I'm going to back up and talk about
why this is important at first.
So the doorway drill is essentially
a first impression drill.
And most people think
their first impression,
I don't think it's up for debate,
your first impression is
very important, bla bla bla,
you never get a second chance
to make your first impression.
Cliche here, cliche there.
That stuff is well known by everybody,
but what most people do not know
is that your first impression is not made
when you open your mouth to say something.
It's not made when you want
to make that first impression.
And that's very important to know.
What I mean by that, and
just to put this kind
of like a funny dating context,
is if you're a guy and you're walking up
to a group of women,
your first impression is
not made when you walk up
and you're like hey ladies
what are you drinking
or whatever you know corny
thing you've got on deck.
Your first impression is made
when you become a blip
on other people's radar.
And so, what that means essentially is
that when they see you
that's your first impression
and the next 20 minutes of you hanging out
with your friends and interacting
with other people and not them,
that makes up the bulk
of your first impression.
It's not controlled by you.
And what that also means,
since it's not what you say to
them when you want to say it,
it means that it's based on a visual
assessment of who you are
and this goes back to
Evolutionary Psychology.
And women are much better
at this than men are
because of the way
that, the safety concern
that women evolved over
hundreds of thousands of years
and the human species and stuff
that doesn't concern us here.
But what this means essentially for us is
that the way that you
sit, stand, walk, and talk
is more important than the
words coming out of your mouth,
especially before you've
actually had a chance
to come up with your clever
little opener and deliver it.
And this is extremely,
extremely important to know
because this changes the
time frame, the window
in which your first impression is made.
It's much, much earlier.
So instead of it being when you decide
to go over there and chat
after you've had three
Jack and Cokes or whatever you're doing,
it's made when you walk down
the stairs into the venue
or it's made when you
step into the board room
for the meeting.
It's not made the first
time you say something.
That's counteracting your first
impression or bolstering it.
It's not your actual first impression.
When I worked on Wall Street,
I used to be an attorney
in a past life here.
And I used to sit in
meetings and conference calls
and think of something
really, really smart to say
and be on my Blackberry and
looking at the case stuff
and I would say something,
I'd be so proud of myself,
and then after the meeting inevitably
one of the partners would
say, "Hey, you know you look
"a little bit checked out."
And I'm thinking I'm the one
who spoke in the meeting.
How am I checked out?
And I'm checked out
because everything I did
before I spoke was
looking at my Blackberry,
looking at the case law,
looking at the facts,
trying to make myself small
so nobody called on me,
just like I did in school, right.
I mean this is very familiar.
So the doorway drill
seeks to counteract that
by building up your
non-verbal communication,
which is actually the bulk
of your first impression.
Because remember, it's
not about what we say,
it's about what we look like beforehand.
And most of us are so self-absorbed
we don't manage our
non-verbal communication.
So the way that we do this
is we stand up straight,
chin up, chest, shoulders back,
and a smile on your face, right.
And you don't have to exaggerate it.
You don't have to look
like a serious weirdo
when you're doing it.
You're supposed to memorize
and sort of get a feeling
for how your body feels
when you're doing this.
And this is very important because
we need to relegate
this the level of habit.
Because what most people do is they go,
okay, my first impression's
made not when I open my mouth,
it's made when I become
a blip on the radar.
Okay, so next time I go
to this networking event
or next time I go out, or
next time go get coffee,
or next time I do this,
I'm going to make sure
that I stand up straight
and I got my shoulders back
and my chin's up, but the problem is
if you try to manage
this stuff consciously
what happens is now I'm
talking to you and I'm,
you're saying something and I'm like
oh is my chin up, are my shoulders back,
okay, I have a smile on my face.
Oh crap, what was Evan talking about.
Oh my god, I wasn't listening.
He's going to know I wasn't listening.
Wait, oh crap, he's still talking
and I'm still, ahhh, negative self talk,
feedback loop from hell
and then the plane just
crashing into the mountain.
(laughs)
And so, what the doorway drill does is
if we remember how this
feels and how it looks,
and we do this every time
we walk through a doorway,
we reset our physiology
to this particular set
of this particular stance,
this particular body language,
this open body language,
positive body language,
we do this even in our own house.
When you walk into your
living room, your bathroom,
your kid's bedroom, your
front door, whatever,
if you do this all the time,
you're going to do this dozens
and dozens of time every day.
And this is going to setup
your physiology differently
so that you no longer have
to remember to do this,
because you're building the habit
of creating this phsyiology in yourself.
And so what that means
that the next time you do
go down to Starbucks
or next time you do go,
or I guess you're in Canada,
so next time you do go down
to Tim Horton's, right.
I grew up in Detroit so I got it.
- We have Starbuck too,
we have Starbucks too.
- I'm sure you do.
I prefer Tim Horton's coffee though.
That stuff is amaze-bomb.
In Detroit, we basically
were a short hop to Windsor
to go get everything, including
alcohol when you're 19.
So that was my childhood.
Explains a lot actually.
But what that means is that
next time you go out the door,
you don't have to worry or even think
about your body language
and your physiology,
your non-verbal communication,
because you have relegated,
hopefully at this point a few weeks later
of doing the doorway drill,
you've relegated this
to the level of habit
so that next time you're
interacting with people,
you're physiology is different.
Your first impressions
are therefore different.
And this creates a virtuous cycle
because when you look a certain way
and you start to behave a little bit
with the way of that physiology,
people start to treat you differently.
And this is something that
happens subconsciously.
We're wired this way as humans.
People treat you like
you're more friendly, open,
outgoing, confident, whatever
sort of positive attribute
they attribute to this physiology.
And when people treat you differently,
this, as we know from
science and research,
is the primary factor
that influences behavior.
How you're treated by your parents
influences the way you grow up.
How you're treated by your classmates
influences the way that you socialize.
So if you change your physiology
and people start treating you differently,
your behavior starts to change as well.
So it's a virtuous cycle.
As people are treating you as an open,
friendly, confident person,
then you start to behave more that way,
which also reinforces your new physiology,
which means that at some
level or at some stage
in the next three, four weeks
and few months after that,
you're going to experience over time,
essentially an identity level
shift, a core level shift
in who you think that you are
and who you actually are.
Instead of being the quiet, meek person,
or instead of being somebody
who's maybe afraid to speak up,
or somebody who feels ill
at ease in their own skin
in networking events,
or in business meetings,
or in a dating scenario,
you start to be treated differently.
You start to act differently.
You start to be differently.
And this isn't meta physical baloney.
This is science-back phsyiology research,
sort of Amy Cuddy mixed with Art of Charm,
Tony Robinsish type stuff in here,
science-based is what
we like to stick with.
And so, the doorway drill is very powerful
because it requires
basically no commitment
other than a millisecond
shift in your physiology
every time you walk through a doorway.
And it will change the way
that people deal with you
and it will change the way
that you think about yourself.
And it changes your abilities
in social situations.
And so that type of
thing is a really, really
high leverage exercise that people
can start doing right way
and see results right away
without like buying something
or figuring out how to
create this massive change
in themselves manually which is very hard
and basically impossible.
- I love it.
So as I'm walking through a door
when I leave this I'm going
to walk through a door.
What are the three to five to seven things
that I need to do with my physiology
to now have that confidence?
- So the recap is essentially
that stand up straight, chest up,
shoulders back, chin
up, smile on your face.
And it's harder to do when talking
because it does look
more ridiculous, right.
It looks like a very fake news presenter.
But it won't look fake if you simply
change the way that your physiology works
because you're not, again
don't exaggerate this too much,
because you don't want
to feel goofy doing it.
You just want to straighten up.
Don't over think it, right.
Just get out of hunched
over computer all day mode,
which is where most of us are,
and get into the mode where
your eyes are actually up
and your chest is actually up.
And no arms crossed,
that's kind of the rule.
You'd be surprised.
Most people don't walk
with their arms crossed,
but many people sit
with their arms crossed
and regardless of whether you're just cold
or you're feeling a little nervous,
it just signals to other people,
look this person's not
in the mood right now.
And so we want to encourage
interaction with us.
We want to encourage eye contact.
We want to encourage a positive outlook
from other people towards us.
And the way that we do that
is really simple signals
through physiology, that's really it.
And it works for men and women.
It's not about being a tough guy.
It's just about straightening up.
So you don't have to worry,
like oh I did my shoulders back,
but I didn't do my chin up high enough.
Like just don't over think it.
That's the number one rule.
- Got it.
And so, if people are
standing there like this
and then they're thinking,
oh okay Jordan said
I can't cross my arms, what
am I supposed to do now?
- Right.
- I can see being self
conscious, oh should I...
- Yes, that's a great question.
It's probably the most common question is,
oh shoot, I always stand
there with my arms crossed.
What do I do with my hands now?
And so, the answer is whatever you want.
However, that's a terrible
answer for somebody
who's an engineer brain for example,
because they're like, ah
no, whatever I want, no.
What's the right answer to this question.
I was a good student.
I need the right answer to this question.
And so, I would say either
if you're holding something
in one hand then fine,
just have the other hand
in your pocket with your thumb out,
that way you're not tempted
to do something weird
in your pocket that looks awkward,
just you know fingers in, thumb out.
Or you can just have your hands resting
like this or like this.
You know just clamped and just have them
in front of yourself.
It's still a little bit closed.
It's not super ideal, but it's
certainly better than this.
What I'm trying to stay away from here is
making people self conscious
about what they're doing
even now that they're straightened up.
Because the truth is it's
just as easy to look awkwark
by doing something like
this while being straight up
and then just trying to
look like a tough guy
or feeling that you're
being perceived that way.
So whatever you do with
your hands is probably fine.
It's just a matter of having that open
and positive body language
and not being as fidgety.
So yeah, if you're used to doing this
and then you find yourself
doing a lot of this stuff
all the time because
you're not sure what to do,
the easiest thing that
we teach the AOC students
at workshops who really
can't stop fidgeting
is just fingers in pockets but thumbs out.
That way it's really hard to fidget.
It's really also hard to do that thing
where you have your hands in your pockets
and you just look like
you're really suspicious,
because you're hiding something.
Ideally, if you're just hanging
out at a networking event
or a business meeting
or something like that
and you have coffee or a beverage,
you hold that in one hand and other hand
can either go in your pocket
or just rest on a table.
It's like I know that this
sounds super, super simple,
but if you start to look at
what we do on a daily basis,
most of us, we're just all over the place.
We're not thinking about it
and we tend to wear our
emotional state on our sleeves
non-verbally which is the
natural state of us as humans.
However, if we look
uncomfortable or unfriendly
or scared when we do that,
it's not doing us any favors.
And it's making that first impression
a pretty poor first impression.
- Let me ask you this,
this is interesting.
Cause I will fidget a lot with my ring,
I know we're both married, I
don't know if you fidget a lot,
but I'll play with it as I'm thinking,
like I like to have
something while I'm thinking
or being creative, not of a nervous
like I'm afraid to meet this person
and I'm like what do I do,
but if I'm in a brainstorming meeting
or having a conversation with somebody,
like the ring is coming
off and flicking it around.
Like I have it on my thumb a lot.
What do you think about that?
What's the message I'm
giving out by doing that?
- I actually haven't seen it
happen that much in real time,
but what that would
signal to me is actually,
and what I think your brain is
probably doing subconsciously
is activating what's called
the default mode network.
And tell me if this is true for you.
When you're in the shower,
are you ever like oh my
god I'm so doing that,
that is such a good idea.
When you're in the shower, driving,
that's generally kind of
or maybe out for a walk,
those are kind of the
top three idea generating
things throughout history.
And if you look at famous people,
I mean like famous inventors,
Edison, Einstein, Thoreau, all these guys,
there's a chart somewhere on the internet
and I can try to find it
or maybe one of us can try to find it.
It charts what their days
were like, from their journals
which of course all of these
guys left back in the day.
It charts what their days were like.
And so every day, a lot of
these guys, Tesla, Edison,
they all took long walks.
Anywhere from half an
hour to three plus hours
on any given day and
that was a mandatory part
of their routine and the reason was,
in retrospect of course,
they're probably activating
their default mode network.
Which is their body is doing something
that's taking up a certain percentage
of their cognitive resources
in order to manage.
You're trying not to drop your ring.
You want to know where it is.
You're experiencing a certain feeling
of having it on your thumb.
Another feeling of having
it on your ring finger.
Another feeling of
having it on your pinky.
That is keeping the
logical part of your brain,
the prefrontal cortex essentially,
busy enough so that
other parts of your brain
which having hundreds slash thousands
of times more processing power,
those things can then fire off
without being corralled
by the parts of your brain
that want to make sure that
the ring's on the right finger,
make sure you don't forget your coffee,
make sure you pick up
the kids from school.
That stuff is all being taken up.
All that processing
power is being taken up.
And that's why your brain can
then come up with great ideas.
That's why we come up with amazing ideas
when driving and then
forget how we got home.
And then we come up with
amazing ideas in the shower
and we think did I wash my hair already.
I mean it depends, pretty soon
I won't have that problem,
but it will be something
else right at that point.
And so we're activating
that default mode network.
It depends on how you're fidgeting.
If you're fidgeting and
you're looking around
and you're micromanaging in your head
how you're being perceived by others,
that's lack of comfort in your own skin.
That's going to put people off.
However, if you're just
messing with your ring
while you're thinking about something,
that's very, very natural
and it's actually probably
helpful for your brain
to be creative while you're doing that.
- Right.
Yeah, I think this whole time I've been...
(laughs)
Just been playing with the ring.
I think it definitely helps me.
I'm not thinking of how people judge me.
I'm thinking, now that you bring it up,
I just probably won't change it anyway,
because I got to be me
but I'm wondering what
the perception would be.
- Well, if you're not worrying
about other people judging you doing this
and you're fidgeting with your ring
in order to come up with creative ideas,
I'm saying don't change it.
- Yeah.
- If you're one of those
people who like me,
I just constantly sip
tea while I do the show.
And I'll sip tea and
then I'll put it down.
And then two second
later, I'll sip more tea.
It's almost like if you saw me doing this
while I was not doing my show,
you might be like this guy is so weird.
Every time he puts his tea down,
but I don't worry about that.
I'm not even thinking
about drinking the tea.
Usually, I do when I'm listening
and not talking of course.
So if the guest is talking,
I'm sipping tea, put it
down, sip tea, put it down,
but I'm processing what the
guest is saying the whole time.
And that's been very important to me.
When I don't drink the tea,
when I don't create something
from my prefrontal cortex to
do while the guest is talking,
I've found over the
years that I end up going
oh man, I'm almost out of cough drops,
damn it, what was he just talking about,
I forgot, ah dang, right.
I just end up with this
weird, kind of hyper brain
that is not conducive to
being a good listener.
So I've learned how to cope with that
by figuring out how to keep
that part of my brain busy.
And most creative types have done this.
That's why you see creatives
doing weird stuff all the time.
And some of the most
creative people around,
unfortunately, have issues with substances
that also limit what that
part of your brain can do.
Because it's driving them freaking crazy
and it's keeping their potential at bay.
Unfortunately, there are side effects
that go along with
alcohol, and painkillers,
and things like that, but
the reason they start doing
that stuff in the first place is largely
because of that creative process.
And you hear creatives say things like,
"I just don't feel like myself
"when I'm not able to insert vice here."
So your ring by comparison
is a very healthy alternative
to meth, heroin, painkillers,
sleeping pills, alcohol,
so go ahead and fidget with
the ring as much as you want.
- All right, back to the doorway test.
I want to understand the
connection with the mind
and I get that the physiology leads
to the confidence in the mind.
I'm wondering is that the only connection
or is there also, are
you thinking something
as you walk through the door
or is it like okay, I'm happy.
Are you telling yourself anything
or is it just I'm going
to do the body thing
and the body is going to tell
my mind to do it that way?
- That's a really good question.
Actually, one of the maxims here at AOC,
and again there's science behind this
that I won't really bore
you all with right now,
the body follows the mind
and the mind follows the body.
And this is like a very, very simple
kind of almost obvious truth
that a lot of people don't think about.
And so, when we do have our
physiology setup correctly,
we do tend to experience
something in our brain
that says all right I'm
coming in, I'm feeling good,
I'm feeling confident, I'm feeling open.
It's all subconscious.
It's not something that
you have to tell yourself.
You shouldn't worry about
like getting yourself
all jazzed up to go walk into Starbucks.
It's really not necessary.
You can if you want to if
you find that it helps,
Sure, give yourself every time
you walk through the door.
It might be helpful to sort
of reduce it to one word
where you just say something
like open or positive
or whatever or you can just say your name.
Like you can just be like, Evan.
Right, I'm in Evan mode now.
I'm upright, I'm confident, I'm happy,
I got my smile on my face.
That's fine.
It can just be symbolic.
Our brains are really good with symbolism.
So if you're going to
create that doorway drill
and you want to sort of have a mantra word
that you repeat in your head
when you go through every door
then go for it.
I, personally, don't use it that much,
but a lot of AOC students do use it,
especially the guys and girls
that have engineer brains where it's like
they need to flip a switch
and it can't just be a
subtle physiology thing.
It's got to be like all
right I'm in this mode now.
It's got to be something logical
that takes them into a different mode.
And if that helps you
then definitely go for it.
But do avoid the self talk where you go,
all right I'm walking in here,
I'm going to be upright
and oh my, there's a lot of people in here
so I got to make sure I do that
because that can spiral into what we call
being in your head which is worrying a lot
about how you're perceived by others,
which is the actual opposite
of what the doorway drill
is supposed to accomplish.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, absolutely.
People on the live chat, first
of all, they're loving you.
Lots of comments, I like this guy,
but also they're laughing because my book
is called Your One Word.
- Oh yeah.
- So it's like tell yourself one word.
- That was a little subconscious thing.
- Nice parallel.
I think of this documentary's on Regis
and every time he left his
office to go into studio mode,
he would also touch the top of the door.
- Yeah.
- Do you ever incorporate that?
Like as your walking through
as a physical reminder
like touch the side of the
door, touch the top of the door,
and that sets you up or...
- You can, you can.
The reason that I think
he may have done that,
and it's funny I haven't
seen that documentary,
but I definitely want to check it out.
He's a funny guy.
I've seen him a lot cause I used to work
at Sirius XM radio and he was in there.
And I remember one time I
was going to the bathroom
before my show when we were
doing it live in Time Square.
And I'm going to the bathroom
and I look next to me
and I see, I look over and
there's this like shorter guy,
I go oh hi how you doing,
you know the polite urinal small talk,
and he goes, "How you doing?"
And I was just like oh my
god, it's Regis Philbin.
(laughs)
Right next to me and man is he tan
for a guy who lives in
New York, really tan.
Oh, I lost my train of thought.
Oh yeah, so tapping the side of the door
and things like that,
that will work especially if
it's always the same place.
I would avoid doing that every time
you walk into the airport,
Starbucks, some random office,
because it can back fire on you.
I've definitely seen there
are times when you can't do it
and you're going to end up
with a physiological hang.
But for example, this
studio, I walk in here,
every time I walk in here,
I walk in pretty much the same way.
I turn on the studio lights.
I have a remote that turns on
some of these other lights,
some of which are off that
you can see behind me,
and I've got all my audio gear here
that has all this digital stuff.
But I got this analog stuff,
because it has just a gillion switches.
And I like flipping those switches
and watching them warm
up and hearing the zzzzz.
I like that because that's like all right,
this is happening, we're going on air,
and I find myself getting a
burst of energy from that.
It's a ritual.
Humans are wired for
ritual so I would say yes,
definitely do it.
If you get to your office
and the first thing you do
is make yourself a cup of tea
and throw in a piece of
Trident or something like that,
then that can be your ritual.
But it shouldn't necessary be something
that you transport with
you every where you go,
because if you can't do it,
you end up with an unflipped
switch in your head
and you'll worry about it
even if subconsciously.
And also, the other
thing is it loses meaning
if it's something you do every time
you walk through a doorway.
Because the point of the doorway drill is
your physiology is going to stay positive
and it's going to change the
way that others perceive you.
But it doesn't have to be
you getting psyched up.
And so, you shouldn't
need to psych yourself up
every time you walk through a doorway.
It would be impossible
to maintain that level
of energy and emotion throughout the day.
So the drill would then lose meaning.
The gesture of tapping the
door would lose meaning.
You see guys, like you said with Regis,
he taps the doorway to his studio.
He probably doesn't do that
when he walks into the can.
Right, he's probably like
this is business as usual.
The other things on camera
in front of a million people,
one is decidedly more
important than the other.
- You got to witness it.
Did he touch the door, Jordan?
- I know. Now I'm like
did he touch the door
before he went in?
I don't know. I don't know
if he tapped the side of the door.
- Cool, man.
Well, it's amazing how quickly
half an hour flys by, man.
- Oh my gosh.
- Really appreciate the love, the energy.
For people who want to find out more
about what you're doing,
your school, the podcast,
where are they going?
- Sure.
If people are listening to podcast,
which I encourage of course,
you can find The Art of Charm podcast
in iTunes or any podcast player.
Or just go to TheArtofCharm.com
and, of course, it's on SoundCloud
and YouTube and all that.
But it is audio only, which is good
because I want people to absorb it
and not just be watching my shiny forehead
here in Studio.
(laughs)
- I love it.
Jordan, you gave so much value.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe
and we'll see you soon.